the problem is is his issue isn't other
multiple women his issue is he's not
where he wants to be financially I think
again Society puts pressure on men to
have to be millionaires like there's
this idea that men have to be so what
would happen if you just said I don't
care about the money like I will I will
work with you like you can do your side
piece thing yeah I'm cool with that too
no I think but it's more him believing
in him accepting that it's not it wasn't
all I want was it because in like the
relationship before was it like did you
is that something you got on him for no
never okay but it's he's con his concept
of women is women will stay with you if
you have money because a lot of men now
especially like the Andrew Tate lovers
believe that if you don't have enough
money a woman would leave you 100 yeah
so this is the problem is me I will
stick by his side with God can I just
interrupt you not to be rude but you're
his wife he chose you you chose him so
what everybody else outside of that is
doing is none of your concern and what
gets my brain is when you're in a
marriage everybody else that really
doesn't matter in the respect of like
you know your parents opinion they can
add whatever but it literally doesn't
matter so Andrews hate social media all
these factors they don't matter they
actually don't matter take them away and
then work on your your marriage or
relationship together
and this is the thing I can say it to
him all I want but again as a man he has
to believe in himself I can't believe
that a guy would leave a full-blown
marriage just because he doesn't think
he's financially safe
you're already married no it's not even
that it's not even that it's men also
overthink what we like the way we
overthink things have you ever have you
ever called him like God on your knees
begged and apologized
got on your knees and said I was wrong
like you were right
yeah we've had conversations we've had
conversations for sure he's not yeah
generally I don't know must be another
reason why I've apologized and he's
apologized and we both agreed that when
he is it's more he needs to be he needs
to accept where he is in his life and I
can't impose for example I think a man
when he knows he's got a responsibility
especially a father a child and a woman
he wants to now make sure he's got
enough money to support and again his
dreams his dreams
no it's not it's not that he's left it's
more he doesn't want us to get toxic and
hate each other so it's more like if we
separate if he was to call you right now
and be like okay I'm ready to like can
we get back together yeah I'll say yes
so the reason that you're not together
is because of him then it's not me he's
not ready yet yeah I don't think that he
can just leave just because he's got no
money
back no no I think you guys are getting
again it's not that he doesn't have
money he's not he for him having 600k in
your bank isn't enough because he feels
like no no again exactly I can't tell
him enough times I don't care if you're
not making millions no it's him to
believe and accept actually do you
believe what do you say it just it's
just like okay like it just sounds like
there's something missing from the story
I I don't know I don't know okay yeah
this is where men have to come in yeah
I'm listening Eddie does a man feel like
women money is important in a
relationship 110 but okay gone if you
were now with a woman but you're not
financially happy where you are
would you break off the relationship no
no you're not a question okay if it's
stressing if it's stressing you out and
you're feeling like I can only focus on
money I can only feel stressed if you're
the reason I'm stressed because
if money is I agree with you in the
sense that men do have a lot of
pressures but I believe that's just the
way it is and and men have to deal with
that pressure becomes it's part of being
the man okay but if I'm married to you
and this is why I think everybody's
gonna start thinking there's a piece
missing because even as a man and this
is me speaking as a man if I'm married
to you the only reason not to feel the
type of way is if I'm made to feel that
way so it's either he feels that way
because of someone which has to be you
or there's something else missing from
the story so now let me ask you this in
a relationship you have to give time
right time and energy when you have
children you have to give time and
energy right if if you felt like you
giving time and energy there was taken
away from what your dreams in money was
would you then why did you not think
about that before you got married
exactly what I'm saying is when we were
initially it was different right that
his goals might have been different
people changed I'm trying to convince
him money's not an issue yeah but Eddie
if you were now putting energy in like
you want to put energy in your business
but you feel like having a relationship
is training your business would you keep
the relationship or would you uh focus
on business I'll do both because I'm
married to you okay now what I'm saying
is if you felt like it was draining like
you felt like you couldn't give and when
I say draining it's not that I want
money I want your time right so as a in
my my relationship I want your time if
you felt like you couldn't give your
partner adequate time and you know
that's the only thing she wants from you
would you feel like you need terminate
the relationship no because I'm married
with a child yeah
it's way higher than that so I think and
this is what we talk about I'm and why I
ask a question about more than women and
selfishness I truly believe that when we
in the relationship it's not about me no
more so whatever it is that I need to
sacrifice to make sure this thing works
is what I have to sacrifice that's my
responsibility as a person who's brought
a child into this world
right
okay sorry when you talk about money
I've always earned more than my man and
I've never made them feel
any different list of a man they've
always paid you know they've always been
the man I've never it's never been a
problem and if you're married and your
relationship with someone
you manage the money you build each
other up you know if like you if you was
married now and you're on I don't know
nine thousand a year
with you and your wife together working
at it they can build you're not going to
say well you know what let's separate
because we've got a kid you ain't got
enough money and we're gonna we're gonna
come back in another three years when
you've got money yeah you're not gonna
say that
you're gonna work it together I'm such
an original so my parents migrated over
here they came here with nothing like to
the point where when I was growing up
they had to switch between he was
looking after me D and that because they
couldn't afford a nanny they work
through these things the girls I'm
thinking if they if they can move from a
land where they know to a land where
they don't know and still manage and
maintain a relationship and still be
together to this day for me to come in
and tell the story there's no reason why
other people shouldn't you know what
happened you know what it is
no can I just say this a million times
over it's because this generation hasn't
faced raw adversity and all the
adversity they face is on social media
so for example like you said your
parents left their country and came here
and made it work your marriage you have
to make it work you have to put in the
effort
I think there's got to be someone else
like missing from the story it's
literally okay I'm not denying yeah I'm
trying to make the marriage work right
it's I can't it takes two to tangle
right again he it might come to a point
in his life that he realizes actually
Surah is there regardless whether he's a
millionaire or zilch and then he might
be like actually I can see it yeah but
it's very hard especially the area he
was brought up in he was around a lot of
superficial people I grew up in Hackney
I came from like Eddie poverty whatever
like my family came here with nothing I
grew up with that that's my reality I'm
not I don't care about designer Goods I
don't care about materialistic things he
needs to accept that I don't care yeah
but the thing is you haven't faced
adversity together and that is the
problem you're not facing your adversity
together I'll say it one more time you
are not facing the adversities together
and that is the problem I I'm listening
to you and I respect that you're you've
been so open because it's allowing me to
understand your story and I can see your
making effort yeah but you are it's like
you're missing the part where you have
to work as a team and that teamwork
means you have to put eye to the side
and make it we are no no no no
yeah this is exactly the conversations
I've had with him yeah and I've told him
we're here we could do it this and that
again I can't change him if he feels
especially where he grew up in a very
individualistic mindset where it is all
about I need to do this I can't have
help I can't yeah but the thing is
because you've got married yeah and
you've had a child which is it should be
the other way around so he before he
married you he should have been working
on himself and came with the money blah
blah blah and said I'm ready you
accepted where he was and he accepted
where you was when you got married now
you can't go you can't put your child
you know back inside your womb and then
she regrows again but what I am saying
is where you are you have to work
through it together because because
you're working
we got a 50 Super Chat and they want
Auntie to say tell us how to keep a man
auntie